there's a player pushing him from
catwalk and vanity gets caught
vanity the 4k to seal the deal and make
chaos your mountain dew league champions
as far as i'm aware it was completely
like the investors some people looked at
numbers
saw they were bad and then yeah there
goes our jobs i guess
this is just a dark horse that you could
take a punt on don't don't expect it to
go far it's only got three legs
just just give it a push out the gate
and see where
through someone's it goes it out finally
he's he's detained
he's gotta stand as watch as v1
against all the odds against all the
doubt
rise above and bring the first win for
north america
above europe
these days vanity is one of the biggest
names in north american valorant
but just a few months ago he was
struggling in the mires of a
dying scene and they just died in in cs
hard i mean you have what do you have
you have eg
you have liquid and then the rest is
just like eu
you know between the pandemic sponsors
pulling out and players switching to
valorant
many n a orgs didn't make it through the
online era of cs go
and among those orgs one name in
particular stands out
vanity's former team chaos esports club
they're stacked up here on bodies
there's a player pushing him from
catwalk and vanity gets
vanity the 4k to take his 31st kill to
seal the deal
and make chaos your mountain dew league
champions
chaos was one of na's hottest teams in
2020.
the mac 10 is coming through and this
could be it two left alive a defuse on
the card but they're not on the bomb
just yet
the head shot is landed by zephyr and
chaos get it done
time ticking away from triumph shake
with the first
but they lose him immediately after
junior it's all on him he needs to stick
the bomb and there's just not enough
time chaos
i've locked it in but just as things
were looking
up the entire org folded leaving the cs
go roster to
fend for themselves me and zeppa had an
offer from genji before they got out of
counter-strike
which was i mean kind of unlucky i guess
but it is whatever
it's esports nothing makes sense at all
i don't even think the players knew they
were getting dropped until they got
dropped but
as heartbreaking as the situation looked
vanity the team's rowdy igl
and cat ear wearing fan favorite was
actually looking forward to a change of
pace
i've been playing the same game since
2015. literally nothing has changed
maybe like the sg and the og came in and
out of meta
for like roughly like six months a piece
and like
so many players before him vanity turned
his eyes to valorent
okay but switching games wasn't going to
be as easy as it seemed
see even though he made the decision to
switch games while chaos's days were
already numbered
vanity couldn't just leave no matter how
badly na was doing or how uninspired he
felt by cs go in general
the game was a monolith while valorent
was a gamble
plus he had to wait until the org
actually folded i mean we knew back in
like
october i think we were getting released
and honestly i kind of like expected it
like
throughout the year because we were
getting delayed payments and stuff we
never had sponsors
so it was kind of just like invest our
money and stuff and that's never going
to last like super long really
when chaos finally collapsed in january
it was time for vanity and his teammates
to get the hell out of nacs while they
still could
i was probably going to end up switching
to valor regardless at the end of my
contract
it was like except probably 70 30
switching to valerian
i was getting kind of bored of
counter-strike and i saw like the just
the path that was going down it's like
not something that
reliably like i could or i could rely on
but
by the time vanity was ready to enter
valorant the cloud9s and phase clans of
the world
already had fully formed squads and so
he had to take whatever he could get
accepting a role as igl with version one
a brand new american orc
i was chatting with jake around the
release of valerian or sometime like a
few months into it and talking about how
i was considering transitioning from
counter-strike and valor and wondering
if
they were looking to get into it he said
they were we were interested in valerian
because
we understood where the developer was
coming from and the approach they were
taking when building this
game v1's valorant squad was a group of
ragtag
misfits a bunch of former cs go pros who
had never really amounted to
anything this wasn't exactly a winning
recipe
early valorent was full of teams just
like this one and
it never worked out no one expected much
from v1
and at first the doubters were right
cause they're down to the last two in a
nice stage while it gets mowed down
quite a bit down to the last
little bit more delta find the ace on
the way out
and tsm burst across the finish line but
practice makes perfect
and by the time any stage two
challengers one qualifier came around
v1 were in a much better place ready to
take on tough opponents and
actually win some games nice edge now v1
they need
this to close things out vanity finds
another it's
all up to zachary it's been huge so far
but it's penny gets the classic out
zachary see you later and v1
they've got time for the defuse they win
in ot
on map three they finally toppled phase
and we've got
ourselves an upset
[Music]
v1 upset phase clan to make it into
challengers where they went on a pretty
deep lower bracket run
now the ice has faded pure goes for a
swing that's a massive kill it's now
down to a 1v1
but it's vanity who comes out on top
version one
take the series two to one paint shells
available as well so a whole lot of
chaos to be created but there it is it's
off the board vanity
with a huge kill and penny to follow up
both from heaven
now taken down they fell in from the
back of the side into the cloud first
they will go poise trying to buy some
space buy some time
it's the blades in the hands it's all up
to one but that's going to be
it version one battle back eight to four
and take the series two to one built by
gamers in cloud9 blue may not have been
the most notable opponents but
those wins secured v1 a spot at the
stage 2 challenger finals
and there they shocked everyone
and that's something that is going to be
once again quickly respond to by cloud9
by pressuring 4c but this time vanity is
more than ready for
spamming the judge the classic comes
through as well
and that's a lovely result for vanity
that's to be sure
and there's the first contact and that's
the position we're talking about the
vanity setup oh we've actually owned
them
so heavily there's nothing that they can
do now they have a main control this is
a really great place to do the post
plant from to retake this
and they i mean they're wrapping around
but the wall from effie's could buy them
just enough time
they're only able to push him from that
what's that vanity pushes right back
poise trading it out boys with the
blades
ladies and gentlemen version v1
tore through the lower bracket beating
just about every team in nna other than
sentinels to earn a spot at valerian's
first
international tournament where vanity
was confident
they'd rise to the challenge like
there's a chance that
like we just go and ever like both of us
and senators go oh and five or whatever
like whatever the group is
i don't think it'll happen i think annie
is one of the more just
simple simply from a talent point of
view i don't see that happening
but unfortunately for vanity v1 were at
a disadvantage from the start
hey guys unfortunately i'm here today to
talk about whippy and we're not going to
be using him
for masters due to covert complications
it was hard for him to get an
appointment
to obtain the visa needed once again
no one expected v1 to do well this is
just this is just a dark horse that you
could take a punt on
don't don't expect it to go far it's
only got three legs
just just give it a push out the gate
and see where it goes
that's my feel on version one right now
and i don't mean that to be
disrespectful to the team i mean that to
try and set
reasonable expectations so people don't
[ __ ] on them if they fail
the team was written off as a regional
one-hit wonder but despite what anyone
thought of their chances
v1 came to win 12 seconds
we're gonna walk through this penny that
is full
n a work right there all flash in the
round probably to follow
any hp on this one they're not finding
the first penny waits
he gets one he moves to the other side
and now scream toss to try it
celsius the timing is everything he gets
one he sees yampi
and then he's starting to show
so calm so collected nobody actually
from liquid falling back here so they
might even just get detained link goes
forward penny gonna trade one out link
swinging through someone's gonna try out
finally he's detained
he's gotta stand as watch as v1
against all the odds against all the
doubt
rise above and bring the first
win for north america above europe
v1's win against team liquid against the
likes of scream himself
was an enormous milestone for vanity and
his team
vanity spent years playing a game where
his talent never got to flourish
playing in a scene that quite literally
crumbled around him
now he was representing na on the
international stage beating some of the
best foreign players in the world
but of course every other team in
reykjavik was just as determined to take
home the trophy
and despite their best efforts v1
couldn't overcome
some of their tougher opponents but
allow as you said is on the flank
cause the problem no penny highlights
this time around as my goodness
it may well maybe happening celsius
drops one
but what else can he do no ladies and
gentlemen bow down to your korean
overlords
as they take down north america and they
advance
and that's it they'll do magic to run
the clock now oh my god
they've only done it fanatic sending
version one home
living through the lower bracket
[Music]
v1 only lost to fnatic and new turn who
placed second and third respectively
so despite placing fifth v1 only lost to
the best of the best
and while losing obviously didn't feel
great the na squad showed the rest of
the world that they belonged
among valorance a-listers we came over
the stand and people thought we were
going to get dead lust i mean we'd be
one of the best i mean we beat
two of the strongest teams in the world
obviously they made it here so they have
to be some of the best teams in the
world
we played the other teams that we lost
to very very close and there's not much
to be disappointed with considering
we came here with less than a week of
practice with our new fifth and
he's never competed at a level like this
before as a player who once faced a
difficult choice between cs go and
valorent
vanity could finally be at peace with
his decision
in just a few short months he and his
team went from na's dark horses to one
of valran's elite
and they're just getting started thanks
for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages